hello students my name is Kirsten Scott
and I am the Teaching Fellow for this
course and absolutely honored to be
joined today by the Honorable Minister
of Health as Rwanda dr. agnes de iguazu
so really just to get things started and
I think it will be helpful to have some
more context with respect to where you
call home where I call home home is
Rhonda and I was privileged to come back
in wonder and work as a pediatrician
because I'm a pediatrician in 1996 it
was two years after the genocide against
the Tutsi and at that time the country
was still totally destroyed
we was sick speedy attrition for a
population of around 10 Millions
and there were no drugs infrastructure
were destroyed across the country as I
told you the morale of the health
workers were not there because and the
trust of the population was not there -
because health professional has
contribute in the killing and also so
people were not feel safe in one hand
but also there was at that time no
possibility to give continuous quality
care according what we know that means
the knowledge the science and evidence
that has been built across the world
what we have to do we were not able to
do it but not only done because the
doctor can do nothing alone we need we
need to work with Nance's we need we
need infrastructure and as I told you
the knowledge of the people that are
working in hospitals was so little you
know that we were losing a lot of
children just because the basic science
the medical science were not integrated
so not only it was not we were not in a
condition
to provide care but the little we were
providing all together was absolutely
out of standard and it was all a process
to rebuild everything in fact the
rebuild the entire system it was really
out of standard and you can imagine you
cannot create a society oriented to
people when you plan to kill a big part
of them so since the Year 60 when Rhonda
was independent the number of doctors
created educated was very few there were
no nurses who have a degree it was a
lower level of cylinder e school then
one notebook we just managed to build
the fire the first library two years ago
there were no real teachers in
university it was people teaching like
that or foreigners coming and teach so
we didn't build the capacity to provide
social services to of our own people and
the little that we had has been
destroyed and the people killed other
people out so that's the context when I
came in a country devastated by the
genocide needed to see it by HIV bite
malaria so it was really a piece of land
where nothing was working